عقوبه جديده تفرضها الولايات المتحده
ومجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي على
روسيا تستهدف ركنين اساسيين في اي مجهود
عسكري الترسانه والحلفاء الموثوقين تستهدف
العقوبات في الحزمه الجديده موسكو لكنها
تضمن طهران وتلوح بالعصا استباقيا دون ان
تسميها
ولهذا تحاول في هذه الحزمه بحسب ما عرف
منها الحد من قدره روسيا على تجديد وتقويه
واستدامه ترسانتها العسكريه في الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا بالاستعانه بحلفاء واضحين مثل
ايران ومحتملين مثل الصين
حكم الغرب سبق وان صدر بحق ايران في حزم
سابقه مسيرات تشاهد كانت منطلقا لتضمين
كيانات وافراد ايرانيين بتهبه تقديم الدعم
العسكري لروسيا اما بالجين التي ترفض حتى
الان الاستفاف مع وجهه نظر الغرب في الحرب
على اوكرانيا فتخشى واشنطن انها تكاد
تقترب اكثر من الانحراف باتجاه الموقف
الروسي فالولايات المتحده بدات تتحدث عن
ان الصين تدرس جديا دعم روسيا عسكريا ولكل
ما سبق شملت الحزمه العشيره قيودا اكثر
صرامه في مجال تصدير التكنولوجيا وصلع
مزدوجه الاستخدام
فاضافت قرابه 96 كيان الروسيا تتهمه
اوروبا بتقديم دعم المباشر للمجمع العسكري
والصناعي الروسي ووسعت الحزمه الجديده من
التدابير التقليديه ضد كيانات وافراد
ايرانيين لتشمل سبع شركات قد سيكون من
بينها القدس وشهد لصناعه الطيران بتهمه
تزويد روسيا بسلع ذات استخدام مزدوج خاصه
الطائرات المسيره بحسب ما اعلنت جوزيفوريل
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
اكثر من عشره الاف اجراء تقليدي على روسيا
منذ بدء الحرب بحسب ما تقول موسكو اجراءات
لا يزال الجدل يدور حول نجاعتها بعد عام
على الحرب